why is there uh cream cheese here oh
this is actually fantastic the hot the
hot Cheetos in the cream
cheese many a day I have
smoked something and just and then and
then kind of forgotten I did it and then
gone and looked at the the cream cheese
the next day in the refrigerator and I'm
like it's covered in Orange residue I'm
like who would do what who did this what
kind of monster would do this I've never
done this though the you're going to be
okay I love how you said I've not done
this before as if anyone else has done
this I I'm saying like is that a thing
is this a where did this come if if
someone so has anyone done this before
is this a standard only you have done
this before is it really true
yeah it's fantastic that is great I
swear to God it's fantastic that is UN
that has no business being that good
okay all right that was delicious I
don't I I'm I'm shocked